[Drum set solo]
I got six cats, but one ran away
Pretty fitting that Ghost was her name (she ghosted!)
Had a boy crucify my heart on Christmas
Spent the new year feelin’ real twisted
But now I’m ten times more ambitious
My career's going motherfucking vicious
(ahh) And that boy about to be a witness
To the limitlessness of how I kill business
Pretty girls, pretty girls don’t cry
We fall down drunk and we fly up high
Even when the boys we love say bye bye
Pretty girls, pretty girls don’t cry
We fall down drunk and we fly up high
Even when the boys we love say bye bye
(Good Riddance!)
Been working on my fitness (yeah)
Mindful when I’m doing the dishes
Baby I can go the distance
Be such a miracle
I’ll be turning you religious (Jesus)
And he’ll be seeing me on billboards
Tryin’ to forget me with some dumb whores (What?)
Just kiddin’ I love other women and if you want to get with my ex then get with him
Pretty girls, pretty girls don’t cry
We fall down drunk and we fly up high
Even when the boys we love say bye bye
Pretty girls, pretty girls don’t cry
We fall down drunk and we fly up high
Even when the boys we love say bye bye
Real queens fix each other’s crowns (ding)
We ain’t got no time to fuck around
We be taking over this whole town~
Uh huh
We deserve black hearts instead of purple
You know what I’m saying girl, this movement’s universal
It’s about damn time for a (re) reversal of this patriarchal rehearsal
My coven is the sickest, my girls are my witches
Badass boss bitches so good that they wicked
It’s true
[Girls talking]
It's so true. OMG I love you.
Empowered women empower other women
Imma take my broken heart and make art with ‘em
And though it hurts like hell I ain’t trippin’
Us pretty girls be on a mission
[Snare solo]
[Anna talking]
Oh, here he comes.
Can I just make like trumpet sounds?
With my mouth 'cause I don't really know if we can afford like an actual trumpet person
[Impromptu trumpet sound and drum solo]
Pretty girls, pretty girls don’t cry
We fall down drunk and we fly up high
Even when the boys we love say bye bye
(What if I'm not pretty?)
Pretty girls, pretty girls don’t cry
We fall down drunk and we fly up high
Even when the boys we love say bye bye
Pretty girls, pretty girls don’t cry
We fall down drunk and we fly up high
Even when the boys we love say bye bye
Pretty girls, pretty girls don’t cry
We fall down drunk and we fly up high
Even when the boys we love say bye bye
[END]
[Anna laughs, gaps for air] Oh good. Ok.
Anna: We'll see if any of that was useable.